what are the roots of circumcision of
infant males in the west what are the
evolutionary advantages if any of
foreskin so okay
this is where we finally get cancelled
i know this discussion and it is a
catastrophe
yep um here's the key piece of
information that you need
um i have deployed years ago now on my
channel something that i used to teach
from which was the
adaptive test a test to tell whether
something should be assumed to be the
product of adaptive evolution and it
consists
of a diagnosis of whether something a
characteristic a behavior or a structure
is complex whether it has uh a
cost whether that cost can be reduced
and yet it persists over evolutionary
time
the logic being if you have such a
structure like the appendix
the appendix is a complex structure that
really is
independently enough to suggest the role
of adaptation in its
creation but to be conservative it is a
structure that can be reduced
so that is to say that the expense that
goes into the appendix can be reduced
over time
and yet it persists which implies that
it is paying the cost
of it and as we discussed last time in
the case of the appendix that would also
be the risk
of having it and therefore the
adaptation is of a magnitude that we can
approximate even if we don't know
what the advantage is now the reason i
go through that
is that in the case of the foreskin and
circumcision
they both pass the adaptive test which
is to say
the foreskin was built by adaptation it
has
a value that more than covers the cost
of its production
the removal of it also has an adaptive
meaning
the removal of it is something that has
persisted
over evolutionary time in spite of the
cost and the risk
of it so what that tells us is that
there's a tension here
between values and it may be
that in some places the
value of the foreskin outweighs the risk
of removal
it may be that in other places the
reverse is true it may be that in some
cultural contexts the value of it
exceeds the cost of removal or vice
versa
and so that is the kind of answer we are
looking for anybody whose answer comes
down to
this is uh this is
mutilation and should be halted because
it has no
value has misunderstood misunderstood
the implication of circumcision
being a long-standing practice whether
you know it could be that the
circumcision is a bit like the appendix
in the sense that the thing that made it
valuable
is no longer present in our environment
and therefore at this point the value is
not there
there's obviously lots of debate over
the implications
for disease so there was a very
popular piece of research that suggested
that it was preventative
of things like aids
it may be that hygiene compensates for
that advantage it may be that that
that data did not indicate what people
thought it did that the methodology was
no good
so it is a very complex environment but
the thing you want look if you're going
to walk away from the dark horse podcast
with something to say on this topic
that will make you more enlightened
than other people it is that both the
foreskin and its removal
are adaptive right that doesn't tell you
which context you should expect
preservation versus removal but it does
tell you you're looking for something at
least complicated enough to deal with
that
set of truths
you